for me they're really just three
essential knives i use regularly today
i'll show you the basics on how to best
choose use and care for each one hey i'm
kelly a culinary producer at tasty and
these are my three favorite knives the
first knife i want to talk to you guys
about is the chef knife it's where i
really suggest you invest your money
since it's what you'll be using on a
daily basis there's two types of chef's
knife there's a western style and a
japanese style the western style has a
bellied blade which makes it easier for
the rocking motion when you're chopping
it also is a thicker steel which is
going to make it hold up more over time
but it is a little bit heavier in your
hand the second knife is a japanese
style knife as you can see it's a
straight edge blade which is better if
you like to do the chopping up and down
motion it is made of a lighter steel
which makes it sharper but it is prone
to chipping out of these two options i
prefer the western style knife because i
like to use the rocky motion when i chop
but at the end of the day i really want
you to choose what feels right for you
before you get to chopping the first
thing you need to do is make sure that
your knife is actually sharp you can
either take it to get professionally
sharpened you can use an electric
sharpener or you can use the stone like
i'm going to show you today this is a
sharpening stone there's two types of
grits there's a higher count and a lower
count you want to start at the lower
count to really get it sharp and then
you just want to get it really wet so
your knife will easily glide across the
stone and then you're going to hold it
at a 15 degree angle and pull it towards
you as you're sharpening you just want
to gently glide it across the stone so
you want to do this about 10 times per
side depending on how dull or sharp your
knife is then get it wet again
and do the other side
so now that i've sharpened it on the
core grit i'm just going to turn it over
and do it on the finer part this is like
gently just making our knife perfect so
after you've done that you just want to
wipe it off and clean off any grit
that's left over on your blade and
you're good to
go so in between sharpenings you want to
use this honing steel a lot of people
might think it's to sharpen your knife
but it's actually used to maintain your
knife it helps realign the blade's edge
in between sharpenings so what you want
to do is hold this steel horizontal and
then hold your knife in the other hand
in a vertical position and at a 15
degree angle just bring it down just
like we did with the sharpening and then
do the back side
now that our knife is sharp let's get to
cutting
so what you want to do is put your thumb
on one side of the blade and your index
finger on the other side then you're
going to wrap your three remaining
fingers around the handle and you'll
notice that you have a really good grip
you'll feel in control and it will
almost feel like an extension of your
arm so you do not want to have a flat
hand like this you will chop your
fingertip off what you want to do is
create a nice claw that will guide the
knife and keep your fingers safe
the first thing i'm going to show you
how to do is rough chop an onion its
name is exactly what it means we're just
going to roughly chop it we're not going
to be precise about it the first thing
i'm going to do is chop the top of the
onion off to create a flat surface then
you're going to cut it straight down the
middle from the root peel the onion skin
off
so now that i have one half of my onion
i'm going to take my knife and do about
one half inch slices going almost to the
root
then i'm going to take my knife and cut
horizontally across the center lastly
i'll cut across the top the other way to
create a rough chop and here's our rough
chop
the next thing i'm going to show you is
the dice this is a more precise smaller
cut that will help your food cook more
evenly so i'm going to dice a potato and
the first thing i want to do is create
an even surface for my cutting so i'm
going to cut the potato down the middle
and lay it flat on my board this way it
won't rock when i go to do the other
cuts then i'm going to take my knife
across the top and just create long
vertical slits trying to be as precise
as possible lay it flat again and do one
more cut down the middle and you can see
we have almost like a baton shape and
it's equal on all sides turn them again
and go back the other way creating about
one half inch pieces and if it's easier
just do a few at a time start small and
then you can perfect your cut this is
our dice so all the pieces are uniform
they're a little bit smaller than the
rough chop and they look great
the last cut i'm going to show you with
my chef's knife is the mince it is the
smallest type of cut you'll see in a
recipe so i'm going to show you how to
do that with garlic first you want to
take one clove off your bowl and use the
heel of your knife to press down
and that will help remove the skin
cut off the little stem and then you're
just going to take your knife and
finally rock back and forth one way turn
that pile another way and finally chop
the other way
and if that still doesn't feel small
enough for you just go back and forth
with your knife rocking back and forth
swiping off any garlic on the blade and
keep going
[Music]
so there you have it here are three cuts
with our chef knife we have a rough chop
a dice and a mince
my next favorite knife is the perry
knife it has a shorter blade than the
chef's knife and i love it because it's
great for those intricate knife cuts
that you might want to do so let me show
you three great ways to use it the grip
on a paring knife is going to be a
little bit different than a chef's knife
you're going to wrap four of your
fingers around the base and then put
your thumb right where the blade begins
you really want to hold it tight so you
have precise control
parry knives are great for coring fruits
and vegetables so for this jalapeno i'm
going to first slice the top off and
then use my knife to go around the edge
to remove that white pith i'm just going
to thinly slice it with my paring knife
so you can do this with your chef knife
but i think it's a little bit easier
when it's smaller so you have more
control so to remove the seats from a
jalapeno i'm just going to cut it
lengthwise to split in half
then i'm going to take the tip of my
paring knife and just go along that
white edge again just to remove all of
those little pieces and if you have to
go around twice don't worry about it and
look it comes off in one piece
and then we can just shake out all those
seeds all that spicy stuff
perrie knifes are also great for
removing the tops of strawberries so
you're going to take your strawberry in
one hand and your knife in the other and
just gently bring the knife across the
top using your thumbs as a base to hold
it in place and remove it and then if
you want to go in and remove the core
just bring it around the center pop it
out
so another great cut a paring knife can
do is segment your citrus it's a little
bit more difficult cut but i'll show you
how to make it easy the first step to
segment an orange is to cut off the top
and the bottom and this is again going
to create a sturdy base so the next step
is to take your paring knife at an angle
and just go along the side of the orange
following the pith to remove all the
white part so this type of cut is great
if you're going to use oranges in a
salad or as a garnish if you still have
a little bit of white don't worry about
it you can go back and clean it up with
your knife so all you're going to do is
take your paring knife at an angle and
kind of cut down in the v motion to
remove the segment so there you have it
a perfect little slice of orange
the next cut i'm going to show you with
a paring knife is a chiffonade and i'm
going to start with some basil i'm going
to take big leaves and stack them on top
of each other try to get all the same
size leaves and then roll them up from
the bottom to the top in a tight fashion
kind of like a cigar so once you have it
all rolled up tightly you're going to
take your knife and just starting from
the front and then going to the back cut
nice even slices and this is different
than the rocking motion you might do
with
other types of chopping you're gently
pulling it back so you don't bruise the
basil so this type of cut is great to
use as garnishes or even stirring into
pasta sauce right at the end so you get
tons of fresh basil flavor the perry
knife is a great tool to have in your
kitchen it is super versatile but let's
move on to the last knife i'm going to
talk about today
i love the serrated knife i feel like
it's a little bit underrated and i like
to think of it as a kitchen saw its
teeth on here make it super sharp and
great for cutting through tough
exteriors
one of the most common uses for a
serrated knife is cutting bread with it
it helps get through the hard exterior
without squishing the soft interior of
the bread you're going to hold a
serrated knife just like you would a
chef's knife make sure you get a really
good grip on it before you start cutting
so i have a baguette here and i'm going
to use my serrated knife to cut it on an
angle to make crostinis so i'm just
going back and forth just like a saw to
cut through the red and you can see it
held its shape without squishing the
interior so if i took a chef's knife to
try to do this first of all you can see
how much trouble i'm having
so you can see that this one is squished
and this one held its shape when i used
the serrated knife
serrated knifes are also great for
cutting through the tough skin of citrus
you don't want to use the chef's knife
on citrus because the acidity can
actually dull your blade so to cut this
citrus i'm actually going to cut really
thin rounds and use my serrated knife
going back and forth just like i did
with the bread to create nice even
slices we have these cute little rounds
that are evenly cut along all sides so
these lemon wheels are great for a
garnish for a cocktail or even putting
it on top of fish or chicken when baking
to add tons of flavor so another way to
cut citrus is in wedges and you would
use the serrated knife for that as well
so first i'm going to cut it in half and
then place the cut side down cut it in
half again
and then cut it in half one more time
and you have a cute little wedge
another cool way to use a serrated knife
is to level your cakes so when you
assemble them they're not lopsided
you're going to insert the knife halfway
through and then rotate the cake as
you're cutting in a sawing motion and
then you can take the top off and have a
nice level cake so this layer will stack
perfectly in a tiered cake
the last thing i want to talk to you
about is caring for your knives first
off make sure you wash and dry them
really well after each use the second is
invest in either a knife block or a
knife guard to keep them safe and sharp
so that about covers it i left a few
links below for my favorite type of
knives leave your questions in the
comments and thanks so much for watching
bye
oh yes
[Music]
you